I mentioned this very emotional
conversation if yeah so I will say this
on a serious note with Kailen is that
she brings out a story a personal story
that is one of the most emotional kind
of revealing conversations we've ever
had on the show we were all very much
taken aback and so was Colton and then
that kind of prompts things in Colton's
life and so it really was something kind
of different it was very different in it
and you know I often joke and I'm like
oh it's the most dramatic thing ever and
and I don't want to do that because it
really does a disservice to what this
conversation is about and and kudos to
both of them for her speaking about it
Colton receiving it the right way and
then having the conversation that he did
it was it was very memorable and
something that's gonna change kind of
the course of this entire show does it
prompt the reveal from Colton I think it
does I think just the conversation
that's had it's on both of their parts
is unbelievably vulnerable open
revealing and I think what one kind of
forget the other for sure Kailyn kind of
started it was something that she let go
and then I think Colton felt comfortable
and I think he felt like he owed her
certain things in that space because she
had just revealed so much personally
would you say this conversation is
something we have never seen before on
the show yeah and again I hate to say
stupid things like that because I do say
stupid things like that a lot a minute
and it's kind of joking or
tongue-in-cheek and and so I hate to say
things like oh you've never seen this
before it's unlike anything because
they're like oh okay we've heard that
before but it really is a depth and
emotion that we've never really faced
before I also want to ask cuz you have
mentioned or called Colton's virginity a
bit of a cocktail joke no should it not
be a cocktail joke it should not I mean
it should but we got to get past that
because I look I don't need to be
throwing stones in this glass house
because yes we use it as a crutch you've
seen leave the poster art where he's in
the four year old virgin get up and the
great thing with Colton and he kind of
reminds me of Shaunie is this great
sense of humor about himself so he's in
on the joke and as long as it's not
mean-spirited I'm fine with it
but I am just ready to move on and so
yes night one there's a lot of the women
Dimmie and some of the other girls that
get out they're gonna make their little
anecdotal jokes about it and it's a bit
of a joke but we'll move on and that's
what I was eager to do was move
to get to the meat of this and why is
coltan the man he is why how has he
gotten to this point and we'll get there
and that's I just want people to know
that trust us we will get there
well you had said that Colton's reason
for being a virgin because I've asked
Colton about this before you know was it
about marriage religion and you said his
reason has to do with prior
relationships and experiences I just
want to know how you reacted when you
found out why he's a virgin it to me it
just everything kind of fell into place
and it made a lot of sense to me there
was a religious aspect to it and his
faith had a lot to do with and it still
does it is something that's important to
him and it means a lot as it should but
then there were other elements that I
think when you just say oh he's 26 and
if he like what like what like he's an
NFL athlete he's you know not hard to
look at I don't understand something was
missing and so for me I guess the best
way to put it is it fell into place
because until you know someone's whole
story you just it doesn't make sense
were you surprised when you found out no
no I wasn't surprised at all I was very
I was VII just had great admiration for
the fact that he opened up the way he
did and I think for everybody you'll be
able to sit back and say the same thing
I did it like okay alright now let's
deal with this and I think for me is the
host producer friend psychologist that I
am it allowed me in deeper and allowed
me to do my job better and be a better
friend be a better confidant but it was
a story he needed to tell and that's the
thing and people you know it'd be easy
for me to kind of say what I need to say
right now but it's his story to tell and
it's his his world to live in and I
wanted to help him that's my job and I
felt like I couldn't fully help him
until he would allow me in and allow all
of us in and he did
you